- Pourquoi les voleurs ciblent-
ils les catalyseurs? Le marché
de la revente explose depuis
plusieurs années, notamment sur
Marketplace. Et pour comprendre
pourquoi, on rencontre
Éric Veilleux, un recycleur.
- On va voir... Ici, on a
un Subaru Impreza de 2011.
- Les catalyseurs font partie
du système d'échappement
d'un véhicule à essence.
Ils se trouvent parfois sous
le capot, mais plus souvent,
il faut soulever le véhicule.
- Et voilà! On est rendus
sous notre Subaru.
- Avec les bons outils,
la pièce est plutôt simple
à scier et à voler.
Pourquoi ça a de la valeur
autant?
ÉRIC VEILLEUX, propriétaire,
Pièces d'autos usagées, Sherb.
- L'important, c'est les mét
à l'intérieur. Et il y a
du platine, du rhodium,
du palladium.
- Le prix de ces métaux
a explosé. Le propriétaire
regarde attentivement
leur évolution sur les marchés.
- C'est parti d'à peu près
500 $ l'once en 2017,
et a atteint, en m
27 000 quelque chose.
- L'once.
- L'once, toujours l'once.
- Depuis une dizai une dizai un,
le prix de revente
d'un catalyseur usagé a doublé,
triplé et même quadruplé,
passant parfois de 300 à 1200 $,
endant les modèles.
- La valeur se trouve
à l'intérieur.
- Après avoir recyclé les
pièces, Éric se tourne vers
des acheteurs, comme Métonor.
treprise de récupération
de métaux. Puis, on va le
raffiner. Ça va venir comme
une... comme une petite farine.
- Marie-Josée s'occupe
du servidu servidu servidu serv.
Elle confirme l'appétit des
voleurs pour les catalyseurs.
MARIE-JOSÉE PELL
service à la clientèle, Metonor
- Nous-mêmes ici, à notre
entreprise, on s'est déjà fait
défoncer. On s'est fait voler.
- Un vendeur doit prouver quproe
le catalyseur lui appartient,
avec son certificat
d'immatriculation.
- Ceux qui volent
les cataux autres,
c'est plus facile pour eux
de les revendre. Ça peut être
sur Internet.
- Il existe un dispositif
à souder pour protéger les
catalyseurs, mais peu de garages
offrent ce service au Québec.
Ici Alexis Tremblay,
Radio-Canada, à Sherbrook